ransomware is being called the digital
pandemic right now as hackers are
finding new ways to disrupt networks
deny access to certain data and then get
paid to regain that access
it's happening to consumers and
businesses alike
there are attacks that are absolutely
targeting consumers
trying to get access to their personal
information
trying to conduct ransomware attacks and
charge their money to gain access
to their photos and their files etc on
the other hand
the places that they work the businesses
that they support
are also under attack so the local
hospital we've seen attacks
on large meat suppliers and we've even
seen on the east coast
a tax that impacted the access to oil
and gas which
hit consumers in their wallets lyndon
brown represents honduras a cyber
security company that helps
organizations keep its customers and
employees secure from ransomware
he says companies basically need 24 7
monitoring
individuals need to be vigilant the most
common cyber attack comes in the form of
an email disguised to look like it's
coming from someone you know a phishing
scam once you click it a malicious file
can be downloaded
or your passwords can be taken so be
vigilant don't click on anything you
don't know is legitimate